بلغت قيمه سوق ادويه السعال العالميه خمسه
ملايين ومين 232 مليون دولار في عام 2019
ومن المتوقع ان تتجاوز السته ملايين دولار
بحلول عام 2027 نمو السوق العالميه لادويه
السعال يرتبط بارتفاع الاصابه باضطرابات
الجهاز التنفسي بالاضافه الى الزياده في
اعداد المسنين والتلوث حول العالم لا
تنصحوا اداره الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه اف
دي اي بادويه السعال التي تصرف بدون وصفه
طبيه للاطفال اقل من عامين لانها قد تسبب
اثار جانبيه خطيره خاصه اذا حصل الصغار
على جرعات زائده عن الحاجه عام 2007 نشرت
دراسه في دوريه امريكيه خلصت الى ان تناول
العسل للسعال الليلي عند الاطفال يعملوا
على قمع الاعراض بشكل افضل من ادويه
السعال اطباء اخرون حضروا من عدم غسل
الاسنان بعد تناول شراب السعال ما يمكن ان
يسبب التسوس حيث تعمل شركات لاضافه الكثير
من السكريات لجعل الشراب مستساغا